美国医生每周工作62个小时，
大部分时间居然不是在看病而是在跟保险公司还有文书系统做斗争。
AI到底能不能解决这些问题？
Hello 大家好，欢迎收听硅谷101，我是红军。
从2025年底到2026年刚开年，AI医疗就打起来了。
OpenAI发布了Trade GPT Health,。
而Antheropic也紧跟着推出Cloud for Health Kill,。
一家叫做Open Evidence的创业公司年收入财以亿美元，
但是估值却飙到了120亿美元，它凭什么？
我们普通人现在问AI看病到底是不是靠谱，
我们这一集就来聊一聊美国万一医疗市场的AI争夺战。
那今天跟我在一起的嘉宾是Fusion Fund的创始管理合伙人张露。
Hello 露 你好。
红军 你好。
还有一位也是我们的老朋友，
他是一串学博士美国药企免疫学的研究员说一解药波克的主理人周叶斌。
Hello 叶斌。
Hi 大家好。
今年其实是一个AI医疗的大年，
然后我发现不管是中国还是美国的这些模型厂商都在开始做医疗了。
露你应该也是刚刚从1月份的JP Morgan的代会回来。
你要不要先跟大家总结一下，
这次代会你有发现一些什么样的新的变化。
对,每年1月份的JP Morgan House Care Conference,。
基本上是美国全年最大的一次医疗盛会。
而且它不只是讨论医疗创新，
它其实更是一个全产业的聚会。
但今年可能我觉得有更大一点不同是说，
大型的药企和医疗公司它的思维理念和前一年是有了一个本质的改变。
之前可能还会有很多讨论是说，
要不要和AR进行整合，
现在很明确的是一定要整合，
而且整合的力度也非常大，
效率包括速度也很快。
当时在大会期间其实有一个比较重要的发布，
就是伊莱莉莉和以美达做了一个战略合作的一个发布。
所以他们会在两边进行非常深度的合作，
而且拿出的预算初步宣布的就是G美金的体量。
那我们也有几个出窗企业，
其实本来就在和伊莱莉和以美达两边都在合作。
他们新的项目成立之后，
整体整合的速度是非常快速也非常惊人的。
包括我和一些比较大的医疗公司的CEO在聊的时候，
经常会听到他们提到的一个概念，
就是公司内部已经成立了像人工智能大学这样的机构。
他们会要求全公司的员工，
包括管理层还有董事会层级的人都要去参与课程的训练，
去有一个基础的人工智能的培训和人工智能的了解。
更好的通过人工智能这样的一个工具去处理医疗数据挖掘医疗数据的价值，
推动一些新的项目的发布和医疗创新公司的合作。
嗯，对，那叶斌因为其实你在要企，
然后自己也是在医疗体制内的，
你自己有觉得今年大家在讨论AI这个名词的时候有讨论的更多吗？
有，其实我们现在平时也有在应用了，
那在医疗公司里面一个挺明显的就是，
要企一般还是比较讲究保密性的嘛，
一方面他可能对于外面的模型他会有一点谨慎啊，
就比如说你的资料能不能上传到chatgbt，
那显然是基本上应该都是不行的吧，
但另外一方面他也希望能够引入这样的，
他往往有自己的做一点公司内部可以使用的，
比如说是microsoft的co-pilot,。
除了要企之外的各行各业都在使用啊，
哪怕是医院他们采用的一些信息的服务商都在引入AI这一块，
这个几乎就是不可避免的，
只不过就是如何是最好的使用方式，
这个现在还都是在探讨当中，
一来立地好像前两年还开放了一个自己的AI的平台吧，
就说你们其他小公司也都能来用，
这个也提出一个挑战就是有些小公司可能觉得，
如果我加入到你的平台我的信息是不是交给你了，
但另外一些公司或者会想到的是，
这样是不是我能够加强和理来这样一个大要紧的合作，
那么现在也确实算是一个百花齐放的状态吧。
嗯，而且除了大家提到的理来跟NVIDIA十亿美元AI。
要务研发实验室的合作，
其实我注意到在这次JP Morgan的大会上，
AnswerRopic他也推出了一个Cloud for Health Care,。
还有一家创业公司叫做Open Evidence，
他现在的估值也到了120亿美元了，
可以说今年是在整个AI医疗领域的一个非常大的独角兽，
我其实也不知道CHATGVT他是什么时候上线的GVT Health Care，
然后我是有一天突然打开网页的时候就发现他上线了这个功能，
而且他是2B跟2C两边都有，
所以现在看起来确实在2026年的这个一开年，
医疗领域跟人工智能的结合，
他是打得火热的一个状态。
待会所有我们提到的这些公司，
其实我们可以一个一个分析一下，
看看他们的商业模式跟他们不同的，
怎么用AI去跟医疗结合，
要有一个非常详细的分析。
那在此之前呢，
我想跟各位也讨论一下，
就比如说从医疗体系看现在中美医疗他的痛点在哪里，
叶斌因为你在药企工作嘛，
平时从你接触到的医生来看，
你觉得他们痛点是什么，
比如说是不是花在行政文书上的时间比面诊还要多。
其实我太太就是医生，
所以我这个比较有比较比较，
他这个也经常和我聊到这一期，
挺明显就是我昨天还去查了一下，
去年10月份的时候，
有一篇论文跟踪的是MGH，
那就是Mass General，哈佛医学院，
他们的附属医院全科医生的一个工作的状态，
最后发现全科医生每个礼拜，
平均工作时间是61.8个小时，
这是非常长的工作时间，
相当于是你可能只有单修，
然后你剩下的6天，
每天要工作10个小时以上，
但是另外一方面，
我们也都知道一个全科医生，
平均每天其实他也就看20到25个病人，
已经算最多了，
最常见的很多时间只有15到20个病人，
那么他每个面诊的时间，
大部分时候其实也就在15分钟左右，
你能超过25分钟是非常罕见的，
如果我们把每周工作61.8小时，
其实平均到每个病人每年要花1.7个小时，
那另外一方面，
他其实看这个病人的时候，
我们都知道没有那么长时间，
那中间的大部分时间，
显然都不是在给病人看病，
主要是看病引入的其他工作，
像刚才红军说到的，
行政工作是很大的一块，
他要和保险公司处理很多事情，
他看诊的记录要记录下来，
这带来很大的一个问题，
一个是效率的问题，
像美国医疗最大的一个成本，
其实是行政成本，
既不是要价，
虽然现在很多人说要价是很高，
这也是事实，
但是主要的成本是在医疗这块，
医生他们花很多时间在行政上面，
另外一个，
由于工作时长长了，
也造成一个比较现实，
就是美国这里的，
在英文里面叫 Physician Burnout,。
你可以理解为医生过劳工作时间太长，
让他觉得没有满意度，
因为你可以想象很多人去读医学院，
不是为了在那里处理行政文书，
不是为了跟保险公司打电话，
交涉是吧，
他希望去看病去治疗，
这个就会导致很多医生，
他的心理上面感觉特别的疲劳，
这都带来很大的问题。
对，你刚提到医生，
在行政问题上花的时间很长，
他为什么这么长呢，
是因为他要跟保险对接，
还是说整个美国的医疗体系，
他在不停的抹块化的时候，
他其实用于流程的时间会越来越多。
是的，就是用于流程的越来越多，
其中和保险是很大的一块，
因为像保险里面有一些治疗，
你需要有Prior Authorization,。
那就是事先的一个要经过保险，
要同意做这个，
否则的话这个钱是报不了的嘛，
那就有谁来付钱的问题。
另外一方面，
作为一个医生，
比如说一个手术，
那他看病之前，
就要先看一下，
他的病例情况是怎么样的，
看病之后他还要做一个记录，
这些都会引入很多的行政的工作，
美国这个医疗本身有比较碎片化，
一个新的病人过来，
有可能他原先的电子档案，
另外一家医院用的和你这个，
稍微不一样一点，
甚至是一样的，
或者大家的记录方式不一样一些，
都会引入很多的很琐碎的工作，
导致整体来说，医疗方面，
我们这个行政的时间和成本。
都是非常的高。
对，我觉得叶斌总结的很好，
其实在美国的话呢，
比较大的一个问题就是，
EHA的系统，
本来是为了让我们更好地做。
自动化和数据化，
但是它反而让医生花了很多时间去，
有点像一个记录源，
一样把很多信息，
转成数字化的一个记录，
还要去审核，
这样的一个流程，
就会导致医生，
他其实付出了很大的时间，
但你会发现，
最后他日常做的工作，
他是一个巨大的资源错配，
就你为什么让这样高成本的人力，
再做一些低价值的一个重复的劳顿？
但现在这就是医疗系统里面存在的。
一个巨大的问题，
包括现在我们能看到，
美国其实这么多的医院，
它大部分都是不盈利的，
也面临的一些比较重大的。
这样财务层面上的问题，
而医生的数量呢，
现在又不够，
其实现在全美国都。
进入到了一个缺少医生的状态，
这也是因为很多医生会觉得，
那我都每周工作六十多个小时了，
但可能只有三分之一的时间，
是在面诊，
去在实际做医生的工作，
剩下的全都是行政工作，
再加上和保险公司打交道，
确实很复杂，
想实险授权，
还有另外一个叫
metacoding, medical bedding,。
也就是到后面，
索培亚深处的过程中，
其实有一个数据是很夸张的，
这也是为什么之前，
大家会看到美国民众。
对医疗工作有这么大的怨念，
因为现在这个整个医疗的支付系统，
它非常的复杂，
比如说医生他要花很多时间，
确保metacoding是做得正确的，
让保险赔付的这个过程能够流畅，
但是还是会有很多赔付的要求会被拒绝，
这个被拒绝的这些支付的要求，
只有10%左右会进入申诉的过程，
但是进入申诉的这些诉求，
它80%都会被推翻，
也就是说它实际上是应该被支付的，
那为什么有这么高的一个推翻比例呢？
就是因为，
实际上它被拒绝支付的原因，
不是医学的问题，
它是一个文书和流程的问题，
所以这就给医生带来了更大的压力，
它如果不把文书和流程过程中的错误减小到最少，
它可能会导致它的病患，
要经历这样的一个流程，
去获得保险公司的支付和赔付。
这样的话你会发现在metacoding 层面上花的时间很大，
但是这个层面它不应该是医生，
却浪费这么多时间去做的。
我记得我之前有一个创始人，
他为什么会出来做这家公司，
就是因为他以前是洛杉矶，
非常顶尖医院的一个急诊师医生，
他有些时候就觉得，
他前一秒可能还在拯救人的生命，
因为急诊室来的人都其实是一个生死，
从往的一个阶段，
他完成了这些工作之后，
还要再半夜可能凌晨三点，凌晨四点，
站在传真西前面去处理这些metacoding，
他就觉得自己的时间，
简直就是完全的错配，
这也是为什么他辞职，
要去做相关领域的一个出创企业，
所以我觉得这点是，
大家可能没有意识到的医生的一个困境，
其实还想给大家分享一个宏观的数据，
在我们人类社会里面，
所有产生的数据里面有30%是医疗相关的，
但这些数据其实很多现在也在被数字化，
被收集起来，
但我们现在真正去应用使用到了连5%都不到，
而在美国的话，
整个医疗体系又是美国GDP的20%以上，
所以这是一个巨大的潜在的情况，
那现在也是到了一个非常好的时间节点，
整个产业愿意去合作，
这也是现在一个非常好的。
时机去做医疗AI创新的原因。
对，然后你刚刚在提到的美国医疗的。
这些行政问题、保险问题、
流程问题的过程中，
你觉得我们刚刚提到了一些创业公司，
就是有哪些他们是在解决这些问题呢？
其实还比较多，包括Cloud，
Cloud它和就Answerpik,。
他们做的Cloud Health for Health。
和其他的几家不一样的一点是，
它其实是在针对做很多。
比较基础的设施的一个路线，
比如说是针对Medical Billing，
Medical Coding,。
还有它的HIPAA System的明确性，
还有一些合规的和连接层的API的需求，
就是它做的一个方向。
所以这个方向，
虽然它不是一个特别性感的，
我们说Sexy的直接通道应用端的。
或用户端的技术解决方案，
但其实对于整个医疗行政成本来讲，
是比较关键的一层。
很多出创企业关注的方向，
也是跟这个方向相关的。
那当然和新手刚才提到的。
最重要的Medical Billing和Medical Coding,。
这两个层面本身就是一个巨大的市场。
另外一方面的话，
它用AI做自动化也相对比较好做，
因为它没有新的数据生成的需求，
很多是一个Rubase的人工智能的应用，
所以它的解决方案相对比较简单，
但是它的系统植入的过程。
可能需要时间长一点，
因为你还是要符合现在所有医疗系统，
包括保险公司对于很多合规的需求，
连接层的一些需求，
哪些数据怎么样去hosting那些需求。
所以这个方向我们会看的比较多。
另外就还是数据隐私，
像我们有一家公司，
它就是我刚才提到的和Ela Lidi，
还有英美达都在重点合作的一家公司，
它做的就是有点偏向于数据隐私的方向，
但它做的是联邦学习，叫Federal computing。
所以它的Federal computing的系统，
第一步就是植入了美国可能60多家大型的医疗体系。
这样的话，医院就可以在安全的律语境下。
把自己的内部数据分享给第三方，
包括说互相的一个合作。
它不用在物理层级上去转移，
或者是分享自己的数据，
它可以直接通过联邦学习的平台。
进行数据的一个共享。
所以这个Federal computing,。
它其实在某种程度上，
也解决了像敏感数据合规的问题。
所以现在在整个医疗领域推行的速度很快，
这家公司也是Ela Lidi重点合作方之一，
而且它们和拆GDP也合作了，
因为拆GDP，
它们也开始在做医疗层面上的应用，
所以怎么样可以把合规这一层先去解决掉，
对于它们铺设应用层是很关键的。
这方面的技术解决方案，
在医疗领域推行的速度还是比较快的。
对，你刚刚提到的这个Matico Billing跟Matico Coding，
Billing我可以理解coding是指什么呀。
比如说最糟糕的一个情况，
就是一个患者去世，那么它死因你就要记录嘛。
在医疗里面很重要的就是，
你来记录下来这个患者中间发生了什么样的情况，
这些都是Matico Coding,。
相当于是有一个代码，你要输进去，
你这里面如果出错的话，都会影响到后面保险，
甚至怎么确定你这个医生在里面到底是犯了错误，
还是整个医疗过程是没有问题，
都会有非常大的影响。
对，但是刚刚陆妮提到了Anthoropic她的Cloud，
她其实是在解决这一块的问题呀。
刚刚听叶斌的意思是，
她其实就是要详细记录你的医疗过程，
当出了问题的时候，
第一是看她的case是不是在保险、
赔付的范围内，
如果真的有医疗事故的话，
她到底她的事故是医生、医院还是病人，
她有一个责任界定。
其实也不是，就是Matico Coding，
还是要把它理解成一个，
有点像翻译的一个感觉，叫医疗编码吧，
就是把医生的诊断和治疗行为，
翻译成一个标准化代码，
比如说有诊断的代码呀，
操作的代码呀，
诊断就是说你得了什么病，
如果你是得了高血压，
它有一个代码，
比如说是iCent，
如果你是糖尿病，
它有对应的一个代码，
就像你在中国，
你有个病历本，
上面会写你得了什么什么病，
但是保险公司它指认代码，
比如说医生它写，
这个病人得了高血压，
但是它的代码标错了，
保险公司是指看那个代码的，
它有操作，
像我们经常讲的CPT Code，
就医生做了什么，
比如说是让你去做新贴图，
做MRI CT,。
医生也需要把这个代码，
它是有一个数字，
比如说9008008300这样的，
去给你标上去，
包括你一些特殊的医疗项目等等，
比如说像救护车，
就属于特殊的医疗项目，
所以这个翻译的过程很重要，
如果你的代码错了，
保险就会第一句负，
据负之后，
医院就要去申诉，
它收款的周期就会拉长很多，
从医院的角度，
医疗服务之后，
它其实是要等着收款，
去支持它一日常的运营的，
所以医院就会给到一身压力，
这就是为什么很多时候，
大家可能只知道 Medical Billing，
但是很多患者没有意识到，
医疗编码其实是非常核心的一环，
而且它是非常非常巨大的，
它是几十亿美金级别的量级，
而且它会直接影响，
像我提到的，
比如说医院的营收啊，
如果你的编码错误比较多，
那对于医院的评估，
也会受到影响，
而且如果说你这个代码，
就觉得说你还upcoding，
它会罚款，
还觉得说你有欺诈风险，
所以你会发现这个过程，
它其实一点都不复杂，
但是却又对错误的容错率又非常低，
那它对于AI来讲就非常非常合适啊，
它首先规则很明确，
它又是个结构化的任务，
它又是个大量重复的任务，
它是有一个明确答案的，
你是高血压就是高血压，
你的代码就是这个，
所以我们其实看到一些做coding的公司，
说实话都不一定需要用generative AI，
其实它就是ru-based，你想想，
它是很简单的这样一个对应的过程，
它可以自动从你的病例提取诊断信息，
然后去匹配代码，
当然用generative AI的话，
你还可以检查说，
是不是supporting documents,。
就是你支撑的这些材料，
是不是足够的呀，
或者说你还可以再做一些预估，
比如说，
我们现在提交的这个，
是不是可能会有被拘护的风险呀，等等，
这也是为什么Answerpick看到。
这个巨大的机会来去做这样的一个解决方案，
你知道它做的是具体的哪几个环节吗？
它有做coding，
feature的话好像有一个是。
他们针对ICD-10的，
一个比较基础的整段代码的，
这样的一个应用，
HIPAA合规这方面，
它其实也有一个具体的解决方案，
HIPAA合规大概是一个多大的市场量级，
然后叶斌尼要不要也跟大家解释一下，
HIPAA合规在美国是什么意思？
HIPAA其实就是关系到我们的一个医疗的隐私，
这是非常重要的，
HIPAA合规可能是，
这个能不能进入医院的一个关键吧，
如果不合规的话，
可能就进不了，
比如说我太太在医院里面工作，
那她和其他人聊到这个病人的情况的时候，
哪些信息是可以告诉谁的，
哪些是不能告诉的，
比如说患者的姓名，
这些可能就是你不能说的，
如果她根本就不是HIPAA合规的，
比如说Chest GPT,。
医生能不能就把一个病人的整个病例给传上去，
那显然是不行的，
一旦传上去之后，
就违反了HIPAA，
被发现的话是很严重的问题，
在治药公司里面也是一样，
要求每一个员工都要进行你的HIPAA的training，
保证在医疗方面的隐私的数据，
你能够达到美国这边的法律的规定，
对，对，HIPAA它其实是一个保护医疗隐私数据，
它的一个联邦的法律，
它其实存在很多年了，
我记得是九几年的一个法律，
它违规的处罚是非常高的，
可能是百万美金级别的，
而且很容易就出发集体的诉讼，
我记得当时Open AI公布了一个数据，
其实很惊人，
它说美洲大概有两亿多的用户，
是在Open AI的Chest GPT上去问和医疗相关的这些话题，
这也是为什么它想专门发布一个产品是针对Chest GPT House，
而且它很明确说，
如果是Chest GPT House,。
你在这里面的对话，它不会用于训练模型，
这个也是为了HIPAA合规。
哦，我了解了。
对，我刚刚还在想，
我说Chest GPT House,。
它是一个特有的模型，
比如说针对医疗系统做过优化的，
还是有什么其他的，
为什么它跟大模型它不能并行去解决，
所以我理解它有一个特征，
就是它的隐私保护是更好的。
对，是的，
而且它其实在House的层面上的数据，
和它普通GPT的那个数据，
它是隔离的，
它也不会混到一起，
这当然是它公开宣布的，
它也强调它跟医疗相关这个Chest GPT House的对话，
是不用于训练模型的呢。
Answerpick,。
因为它做的其实是跟偏向于基础设置一个层面的嘛，
所以他们明确的就是说，
他们一定是提供HIPAA合规的云部署，
因为云部署主要就是三个平台嘛，
AWS,谷歌和Azure,。
这三个层面上，
它说它很明确，
一定是HIPAA合规的部署，
而且非常强调说，
你的企业是有直接控制数据的，
比如说我是一个医院，
我用了Cloud for Housecare,。
但是这个数据的控制一定是在我手里，
而且它去连接这些，
我们刚才做coding的数据库的时候，
它说它是一定连接的是官方的数据库，
所以它提供的是一个企业的底层解决方案。
在某种程度上，
它可能也会避免了更加复杂的，
因为如果你和用户断的话呢，
你可能产生的这个应用场景会更加多样一点，
造成的这种隐私相关的风险会更高一点。
所以我其实觉得Antwerpik在Cloud for Housecare这方面的打法，
还是非常非常聪明的。
对，我确实觉得在大模型走向垂直领域的应用的时候，
在美国这点尤其重要，
包括它不仅仅是在医疗，
可能在法律，
在各种涉及到用户敏感数据的行业，
它可能都是一个门槛，
就是大家担心的第一个问题就是隐私的问题。
是的，所以这也是导致，
确实在医疗AR这个领域的话，
你会发现很多早年的公司，
它会直接做这种to consumer的，
或者说更偏向于清整段，
或者是lifestyle,。
但是其实你真的要去抓住这个巨大的医疗AI市场，
还是要符合所有的这些审批合规的一些过程，
才能够抓住这个最大的市场。
很多AI创业公司，
它就从一开始，
它不仅要考虑它的AI模型能力，
应用解决方案的一个整合能力，
它也要考虑安全团队，合规架构，
还有相关的审计，
法律层面上的考虑和整合，
你再和医疗企业和医院去合作的时候，
它确实还会有一个安全审查的周期，
你也不能够随便的抓取所有的这些数据，
去做模型训练，
就像你讲的，
为什么在医疗领域，
我们看的公司都是这种小语言模型，
它不是大语言模型，
它做小语言模型一方面是说，
它的数据质量确实比较高，
它可以通过有限的高质量的数据，
进行特定应用场景的优化，
但更重要的是小语言模型的话，
你在未来可以有可能去做本地化部署，
那本地化部署的话，
在隐私合会这个层面上的空间，
就会更大。
嗯,对,
刚刚我们是分析了Personal Peak切入的模式，
我们再说一下OpenAI，
就是我注意到OpenAI，
它其实同时推了两端，
一端是它的chatGBT health，
就是我们刚刚提到的，
它是面向与普通用户的，
大家可以通过连接自己的。
苹果手表的健康记录，
医疗记录，
包括自己的锻炼数据的记录，
在上面去问一些健康的问题，
那还有一个呢，
就是它是chatGBT for health care,。
它是面向与医院的，
然后注意到有六家医院，
是跟他们进行了一个手批的合作。
你们怎么去看OpenAI，
它切入医疗的这个模式，
就是我的问题其实可以拆分成两个，
一个是它2C的这一端，
除了它可以更加保护患者的隐私，
它还有什么特别的吸引力，
然后2B的这一端，
它是怎么合作的？
对，其实OpenAI它做house，
我觉得有两个动力，
一方面是因为OpenAI，
其实从去年吧，就开始在考虑说，
自己怎么样向2B去转向，
因为C端的话呢，
确实付费是一个巨大的问题，
而且2B,
其实你就要看哪个市场比较巨大，
而且它有海量的高质量的数据，
适合去做初始的2B的这些整合，
那医疗当然就是一个巨大的市场，
一方面美国GDP的20%都在医疗系统，
30%的人类社会的数据医疗相关，
现在应用的比较少，
不代表它没有数据化，
它其实在医疗系统里面的数据化的程度是非常高的，
也是得利于我们刚才提到的这些非常巨大的行政压力，
医生其实相当于就有点像做数据的整合，
数据的深层，还有数据的labeling的过程一样，
它把这些数据化的数据都在H2的系统里面，
还有在医院的体系里面，
所以我觉得从OpenAI来讲的话，
一方面是希望在2B层面上，
通过医疗体系去进行一个巨大的商业化的探索，
增加它的2B的收入，
二来的话呢，
这个行业的数据也是海量的高质量的数据，
我们也提到过OpenAI，
它其实现在面临一个挑战就是怎么样可以去进一步的提升模型的能力，
那在现在这样一个大量的数据的基础之上的话，
数据的质量比数据的数量更重要，
所以C端持续去加更多的数据量，
可能对它的模型能力的提升非常有限的，
但是如果是在B端可以去通过2B的推广，
去拿到更多的高质量的比如说医院内部的数据，
对于它模型能力的增加是非常有益处的，
所以这是一个商业化层面上的探索，
同时也是一个模型能力战略层面上的一个探索。
对，叶斌又不充满。
路说得非常好，我们说了很多行政，
但医学本身也是一个科学嘛，
每天都有大量的文献出来，
这就有大量的知识更新的一个过程，
在过去一生，反正它每年都要去修多少个这样的学分，
相当于你在了解最新的一个知识，
但这个过程肯定也是不平均的，
不是每个医生的知识都更新得很快，很及时，
或许你同一个医院看不同的医生，
也可能给你的治疗的方案也会有稍微有不一样一点。
CHAT GPT for Health Care,。
我至少看到他们的介绍，
似乎是这两个方面都有一个提升，
一个是行政方面的事先授权的文书，
它帮你来转写，
另外一个方面，
它是可以有很多大量的研究，
公共的一些诊疗方案，
比如说看到一个病人之后，
它可以帮助你，
设计一个可能比较好的诊疗的方案，
但我个人觉得这两个方向，
不论是把最新的诊疗方案，
保证你每个患者你的诊疗，
都是尽量的更加合理，
还是在行政成本上面的降低，
对整个医疗显然都是非常有意义的。
对,
刚才因为讲了好多CHAT GPT for Health，
这个C段应用，
但我可能要补充一点，
OpenL它其实也专门强调了。
它那个C段那个产品，
它有非常明确的免责声明，
它非常明确说你还是要咨询医生，
它并不进入诊断领域，
所以它其实还是要控制它的医疗风险，
所以从用户来讲的话，
也不要完全去信它，
因为它还是很明确说，
它不承担责任，
这也是为什么它在C段的产品，
它其实会觉得自己的灵活度会更大，
但是B段就不一样了，
它希望当然是为了成为医院级的AI操作系统，
并不是一个工具，
它想直接去准入到工作的流程，
成为基础层，
甚至说它现在其实很大的一个趋势，
就是Agent嘛，智能体，
它希望成为一个开发平台，
可以让医院在它的这个平台上，
开发各种各样的智能体，
所以我觉得它的野心还是很大的，
而且它其实你想刚开始，
如果我们看到其它的一些Housecare AI的应用的话，
它其实比如说可能会是一个独立的App独立的一个产品，
但是OpenAI它是希望说，
我可以跟你的内部的EHR的工作流程直接去整合，
我直接去给你自动总结，
自动补充资料，解释，
但是这个过程很有意思的一点是什么呢？
大部分医院它用的软件系统其实是微软，
那微软的话呢，
现在在2B层面上和OpenAI其实是有一个竞争的关系在的，
所以它想欠入工作流程，
但微软的产品已经是在工作流程内部陷入到里面去了，
所以我们也会很有意思，
我现在其实也在关注微软它的反应会是怎么样，
就比如说像病例自动总结，
这对于微软来讲，
如果说医生用的都是Outlook的一个系统，
Microsoft的整体的一个系统的话，
Office的系统，
其实它是一个非常容易内部增加的一个新的feature，
而不像OpenAI这样的话，
它也是要去进行整体的一个系统整合，
那OpenAI它现在也在说，
我们是一个开发平台，
医院也可以在上面构建你自己需要的这些智能挺，
就像我们刚才提到的这个编码，
这个Medical Coding,。
还有辅助沟通啊，
你都可以在我们的平台上去建立新型的智能挺，
所以你会发现它进来还是一个生态打法，
它虽然一开始有应用端比较多，
但它还是进来说我希望成为你所有的一个生态，
也新当然很大，
而且生态打法可能也会对于他们未来的价值最高，
但我并不知道这样的一个生态打法对医院的接受度有多高，
其实现在它合作的医院数量还是比较少的，
我记得斯坦福这边是儿童医院在跟他合作，
但目前还没有听到比较多的一个反馈说，
这个整合速度有多快，
对，我觉得这个还挺有意思的，
感觉美国这些大的巨头，
他们其实是在抢占AI的，
我可以理解是他们的一个SAS系统，
而且你刚刚提到说，
现在整个医院他们用的系统是现在微软的Outlook，
因为其实现在整个模型的质量，
他们已经在慢慢的拉平了，
他们如果能在不更改现有基础的情况下，
只是升级软件，
让Outlook它有各种的医疗总结的能力，
其实我觉得也可能是走得通的，
所以这一块竞争还是感觉还蛮火热的。
对，而且其实你能看到，
最近还有好几个开源生态模型的一个发布，
所以你会发现可能在过去这些年，
现在是开源模型能力和避源模型能力，
彼此之间的gap差异最小的这一段时间，
开源的这些模型既便宜又好用，
那对于很多高监管行业来讲的话，
他们确实也有可能去考虑有些太敏感的数据，
太敏感的应用，
是不是可以以低成本的方式直接自己内部去建，
或者说出创企业可以更加低成本的方式，
更快速的迭代方式，
把这些用场景搭建起来，
然后去和这些行业军营合作。
只是说在这个基础之上，
我们要考虑为什么要做小野模型，
做特定的垂直领域的部署，
就是因为要消除幻觉吗？
那在医疗领域的话，
你不像C端的应用，
你对幻觉是没有容忍度的。
所以这也是为什么，
我们现在虽然看到很多公司去做医疗相关的AIA诊，
但我们总是需要Human-ing的loop，
就你还是需要医生，
就医生去使用它，
而不是说用它去替代掉医生。
那我们刚刚分析了OpenAI与AnswerRopic，
这两家巨头在医疗领域的动作，
那接下来我们聊一聊开头提到的。
创业公司OpenEvidence。
我觉得它也是今年整个医疗领域的一匹黑马。
2026年1月份的时候，
我看它的估值是达到了120亿美元，
然后有40%的美国医生，
每天都在用。
它比较有特色的一个事情是，
它是跟美国的顶级的期刊检索综合，
然后带出来的一个回答，
而且说它跟期刊之间都是签了一些独家内容的合作的。
大家怎么看，
它从训练数据上跟模型上，
相当于它是一个帮助医生的模型，对吧？
对的，美国的医生，
通过这些顶级的刺刊，
还有一些国家的一个标准的最新的诊疗方案。
如果医生遇到什么问题，
他可以直接去问，
然后他会给出一个，
基于比较强的医学科学权威证据，
来给出一个回复。
它解决了一个问题，
我觉得或许是，
如果我们去问ChatGPT，
那有时候问一些医学问题，
他确实会出现幻觉，
或者他找的医学证据的层级，
可能是有一点问题的。
比如说，我太太也试验过，
就是让ChatGPT帮我宗述一下，
这个领域最新发展的什么，
他就有时候会出现他的幻觉，
他会编出一些文章，
他说发现了什么东西，
那个在医疗领域里面，
肯定会有很大的问题了，
特别是如果医生，
比如说我遇到一个糖尿病的病人，
现在的诊疗方案，
应该是怎么样的，
如果这时候你出现一个幻觉，
那后续的问题就非常严重。
Open evidence我理解,。
如果他用的完全是最顶级的权威的期刊，
然后又限制在了标准的诊疗方案，
那么他把他的数据的质量，
以及他的回答的质量，
都控制得非常好了。
同时他也针对的目标人群，
非常简单，
他就是针对医生，
甚至他针对医生也就做一件事情，
就是你需要最新的知识时，
我就给你最新最权威的知识，
没有别的想法，
他不是要给你做其他很多东西，
最后让他这个质量可能是非常的稳定，
这或许是为什么他现在那么成功，
有那么多医生愿意去使用他。
那我理解他这个不就是一个开放的，
把这些资料输入进去，
一个更加智能的搜索库吗？
只是说你这个搜索容录了更多的智能而已。
就像你刚才对他的一个评断嘛，
他其实是一个高度优化的一个rec，
就是一个retrieval的架构，
从医疗领域的应用来讲的话，
对幻觉是容忍度很低的，
同时的话，
医生对于他很多的引用啊，
还有信息他是需要非常精确的。
所以其实你可以想象说，
他这个rec的架构想做成的一个结果，
就是他相当于是把这个模型有一个比较好的一个限制，
去保证他不要自由发挥，
不要有幻觉的内容，
你所有的内容必须是来自于你检索到的那些授权的内容，
另外他不是也有很多授权的信息吗？
那他在里面找的这些信息都是高度准确，
而且是高质量的。
那最后你的这个输出就是给医生提供的输出，
你也必须是由他的出处，
他就可以保证他的真确率。
在这样的一个应用场景，
你会发现说他能够做到的结果，
就是他基本上可以去降低或者消除幻觉，
内容也是非常高质量的，
他是一个结构化的检索，
他不是一个random的解锁，
而且他也没有这种所谓的，
我们经常讲深沉实爱的这种创造性的推理。
所以他的模型优化的能力主要体现在，
比如说他一来就是你说的这个检索和筛选，
他直接入了高质量的医学的信息和数据库，
他没有互相关的，
或者甚至我们说垃圾信息的影响。
同时他其实还是针对这个医疗场景，
他去进行了优化，
你在医疗场景的对话的内容，
应该怎么样进行专业度的对话和你，
实际上用无论XGPT，
Anzorpic Cloud会进行的这个语境，
还是不太一样的。
当然我知道，
大家觉得他也是一个比较火爆的公司，
然后估值也很高，
但我并不觉得他是一个具有核心AI能力的公司，
当然他做了很好的rag的一个架构的优化，
我觉得他的核心的一个竞争能力，
实际上是他的信息是他的数据，
就是他能够拿到这些高质量的医学内容的一个授权，
而且他又在很短的时间之内，
进行了很快的大规模的对于医生使用团体的渗透，
所以现在使用率也很高。
所以他并不是说是问整火怎么样，
他其实就像你说，
他是一个医生对于临床的一些信息的一个搜索，
还有整合的工具，
而且他速度很快，
对于相对比较年轻的医生来讲，
现在使用率是非常高的。
但是你会发现他的商业模式呢，
就是你可以说他商业模式很聪明，
但是我也不知道他有多可持续发展，
他现在的年收入大概是一亿美金左右，
当然增长送的是比较快的，
但是所有的医生是免费使用的。
他怎么赚钱呢？
就是像广告商一样的赚钱，
比如说是医疗广告，
还有内容推广，
还有将来他可能也会做企业版本。
所以他其实用的是哪部分的预算呢？
你想所有的医药公司，
他其实都有药物代表，
要去医院里面和医生打交道，
在这个层面上他的预算是非常高的，
包括去说服一些医生说，
你要考虑用我的药，
你要考虑向患者推荐我的新药，
他是非常高的一笔预算。
那现在呢，
这部分大的预算，
他拿出一部分小一点的预算，
直接用在Open Evidence上面，
那只要你是一个免费的医生用户，
你就每天在看到他的这些广告的信息。
对于很多医药公司来讲，
他可能在做药物代表推广的时候，
他针对的是一些医院或科室里面。
比较核心的医生，
但年轻医生的话，
可以通过Open Evidence上面的广告。
去潜移默化的影响，
他对药品的推荐和判断，
致使他的一个商业模式。
有些时候你就会考虑说，
那医生的医学的这个科官信，
你怎么保证，
比如说，
药物公司想推广某种药，
那在医生问问题的时候，
他是不是会优先去推送。
和这个药相关的一些研究成果，
这个也是他未来商业模式。
可能遇到了一个挑战之一，
那现在他的估值确实比较高，
应该是有12个别点，
但你想想他的收入，
只有一亿美金，
那我们可能对这个公司。
还是处于一个观望的态度，
C端的潜移成本是比较低的，
所以对于医生来讲的话，
他如果说有另外一个解决方案，
也是免费的，
而且可能没有这些广告，
层面上的这些科官信的考量，
而且你也可以直接使用，
或者说未来，
比如说Gemini Cloud,。
或ChangePthouse,。
直接在你日常使用的AI的应用里面，
你直接加了一个医疗的，
附属的新的独立的应用，
那OpenAvidence,。
是不是还有现在这样的一个优势？
所以我觉得这些都是。
值得关注的未来的一些发展点。
对，他们是用一个reg的方式，
然后在解决很多医疗跟医生，
在使用模型过程中的准确性的问题。
关于AI医疗的模型的话，
我觉得他们还要解决一个巨大的问题，
就是因为你给人看病，
你不能出现任何的错误，
也不能有幻觉，
垂直的医疗模型，
跟垂直的医疗预料的训练是有必要的吗？
还是说他会被大模型的能力给覆盖掉？
我个人觉得还是有必要的。
OpenAvidence其实就是个例子嘛，
它都不是垂直了，
它是垂直里面引出很小一块。
我们都说的是AI如何去帮助医疗，
那AI有时候对医疗有一个坏处，
那现在有很多文献工厂，
发很多文章嘛，
很多灌水的医疗文章论文，
可以让AI来编一篇，
就发表出来了。
这个实际上造成一个数据污染。
你像OpenAvidence,。
它做的非常垂直，
做的非常非常小。
它限定了自己数据的来源，
但另外一方面，
它也提升了这个质量。
这或许是垂直领域的一个优势吧。
因为如果你是完全的大模型，
我的理解可能还是这方面的风险相对大一些。
它引用的数据肯定会引用更多。
你比如说一旦提到Health，
那它可能会往上，
在美国这儿有那些。
wellness influence,。
健康领域的一些人，
它提出一些观点，
它或许也会引入到里面，
因为那些东西有很多人信啊，是吧，
网站上面还是有很多引用。
但是这个和新英格兰区。
杂志上面的这个论文，
从证据的质量和可靠性上。
还是有很大差异的。
如果是垂直领的话，
这可能是它的一个天然的优势了。
对，路怎么看？
我非常同意叶斌说的，
我觉得医疗AR领域是一个。
非常需要垂直与研模型的。
应用的方向，
就是因为它的专业性数据的质量，
包括它应用场景的多样性。
虽然我们讲说医疗行业非常巨大，
我们想想有多少类不同的疾病，
多少类不同的医疗场景，
多少不同的医疗数据。
数据虽然总体量很大，
但它的多样性，
还有个体的一个特质性也非常强。
所以在这个基础之上，
它对幻觉的容忍度有很低。
垂直领域应用我觉得是非常好的一个方向，
而且也会是一个很快速迭代的方向。
再加上医疗领域还有一个天然的特点，
就是它其实有很多边缘设备，
海量的医疗期限，
还有电子化设备，
在智能医院的普及。
然后设备上面都可以去进行端的AI的部署。
那如果你要做端AI的话，
那必须是一个小模型啊。
否则大模型的话，
你在端层面上很难去运行，
因为它的量积太大了，
耗电量，算力的需求等等。
再加上我们提到医疗领域，
它不管怎么样都是高检管行业，
那数据隐私的要求，
你就不可能把所有的数据全部传到云端，
你还是希望说哪怕云端符合HIPAA，
你也希望说有些核心数据是在本地化，
这不仅是医疗行业的需求，
甚至说是中端患者的需求。
那我当然希望说，
我最敏感核心的数据是在本地部署的，
而不是说在云端部署的。
所以我觉得所有这些医疗领域的特性，
就哪怕说我们说的整体的大模型，
快速发展能力继续去提升，
我觉得因为刚才我提到的这些医疗领域的特性，
它还是会更适合于垂直小模型的特定用场景的。
这样一个部署和发展。
另外的话呢，
其实刚才叶斌说的也非常好，
因为刚才你问的叶斌那个问题，
我们对于AI幻觉在医疗领域怎么看，
我刚想到的也是自动驾驶的例子。
现在我们其实对于医生和人工智能，
解决方案整合的这个角度的需求，
有一部分确实是要承担责任，
就是到底如果说出现了医疗的问题，
谁来去承担这个责任，
谁最后有一个最终的解释权。
一方面也很难去说是AI的问题，
是这个技术平台的问题，
有一个特定的人或医生会更好地去进行追责。
还有另外一点的话呢，
说我们也要有一个尽慰度，
是医疗领域还是不停地迭代发展，
人体是非常复杂的一个系统。
那从医生的角度，对于一个病人，
特种疾病是进行偏保守的治疗，
还是偏激进的治疗，
甚至说每个人个体之间，
疾病的反应和反馈都不一样。
所以这个东西一部分，
你可以相信AI去帮你进行一个鬼华，
但有一些部分你也没有办法去通过。
一个单纯的数据去体现出来，
包括很多的BioMarket，
我们现在还不明确，
就是我们的数据虽然已经很巨大的，
就像我们有一家公司，
它其实是通过这种智能，
交囊一个微信机器人，
收集长到的群群的数据，
Michael Byum Data,。
但这个数据，
它不只是和长到的，
比如说一些癌症类疾病，
消化道系统疾病相关，
它其实是脑部疾病，
尤其是帕金森的一个生物标击物，
这些数据我们现在还没有，
那我们就没有一个完整的数据基础，
去让AI进行更加全面。
和整体的个性化的分析和判断，
这就是为什么我觉得，
在医疗未来发展的方向，
当然个性化的方向，
数组化的方向，
医疗和AI整合是一个必然的方向，
但是我们总是需要，
human in the loop,。
需要医生在使用这些工具，
作为一个主体，
去进行最终的一个判断。
对，我觉得这个里面，
可能还分为几个层次，
就是你刚刚提到的帕金森，
它可能已经是一个非常严重的，
大家真的有了病，
要治疗的一个程度了，
其实治病的难度，
越往上走，
它的医生数也越少，
也越专业，
同时我觉得还有一部分的需求，
就是很多人，
我不知道你们有没有，
有时候觉得自己有点不舒服，
问一下AI是怎么回事的，
我有时候就遇到一个。
不知道该怎么处理的疾病的时候，
问一下，
大体上它还是能判断，
它还是能给一个正确的方向的时候，
就是这种不要出急的，
比如说有时候大家感冒，
失眠怎么办啊，
这个时候AI它是不是也是一个，
还挺有帮助的工具的？
当然是啊，
这就是为什么，
你会看到2亿多人，
每周都在拆GBT上问医疗相关的问题，
而且它这些海粱的数据，
确实可以提供一个非常快速的反馈，
包括有些时候，
有些人他可能会把自己的一些，
测血的数据啊，测血的结构，
提交给AI，
另外刚才叶斌也提到一点，
其实医疗资源还是不平均不平衡的，
包括在美国，
在中国都是这样，
大家都希望看到最好的医生，
但最好的医生时间有限，
它也不一定有所有的数据去做这个判断，
它有多少时间可以去整体的观摩，
给你所有的这些持续监控的一些数据，
那可能有些偏远的地方，
它的医疗资源也相对比较落后，
那这个时候，
AI的平均水平，
就会高于比较落后地区的医疗水平，
这就是为什么，
刚才讲说，
未来的方向一定是要做AI和医疗的整合，
但是我也不希望大家就盲目的去相信，
AI的能力，
觉得它可以解决所有问题。
对,
这也是我非常想问的叶斌的，
比如说你自己有点不舒服，
或者家人有点不舒服，
你会去问AI，
然后你觉得AI给的整段建议，
现在是可以相信的吗？
我会啊，
很多时候我觉得还是挺有道理的，
一个问题不光是用不用AI，
还有一个问题就是怎么用啦，
如果你得到一个答案，
你是完全相信AI，
还是你想办法继续问这个AI，
继续用更多的问题去提问啊，
确定它是怎么推出这个结论的，
它的依据是什么，
这个可能可以帮助你来更加的了解，
AI的判断到底对不对，
在这里面，
其实AI给大家做了一个事情，
其实就是一个分层整聊的事情，
好比在中国大家的一个习惯啊，
只要一有病都是往三甲医院跑，
是吧，你在城市里面都是往最大的这个医院，
基本上不太可能有人去旁边的一个。
什么社区的诊所去看病，是吧，
有些人可能他真的有病，
真的需要看，
但他一想到医院里面要排那么长队，
他有些人也就不太愿意去，
甚至有很多人可能连体检都不想做，
这个都是最终会导致整个的医疗的效率不是很高，
也有资源的浪费，
同时我们自己也没有得到很好的医疗服务，
有很多简单的问题，
如果可以通过AI先来处理，
这实际上对未来是很有好处的，
像在美国他们有些地方可能也希望尝试吧，
你比如说急诊师进来一个人，
美国的急诊永远都是要等很久，
等的过程其实就是一个判断，
就说你这个人，
是不是真的就立刻要去看这个病，
还有一些人可能稍微等一下，
这个过程在有些情况下，
如果可以加入AI，
或许能够让他处理的更加合理，
同时也让急诊一般都是亏钱亏的最厉害的一个部门吧，
急诊是亏钱亏的最厉害的部门，
为什么？
美国这儿有一个保险赔付，
那有些人可能他没有保险，
但他最后都拖到大病了，
那他就去急诊，
他由于没有保险，
那么他能够赔付到的钱都是非常有限的，
有些政府可能会给一些钱，
但都是比较有限，
就会导致急诊，
一般来说在有些医院，
可能都不一定愿意开这个急诊，
但现在有一些急诊全都被另外一些公司给买过去，
来做他们有其他的方式，
来把他收入给增加上去，
但他往往增加的不再是传统意义上的急诊那一块，
在急诊里面，
如果我们可以更好的把病人给分流分层，
那么也是会提升他这个服务，
同时也可能让他的效率运营更高一些，
尤其在一些偏远一些地方就更加有必要了，
因为那边可能人手不足，
那是非常明确了，
像我们在问AI问题的时候，
可能取代了我们去三甲医院排队的时候在中国的话，
那在美国的话，
可能你是打电话找家庭医生，
这也是一个分流分层，
由于我们医疗的资源的局限性，
这种分流分层，
我个人感觉都是非常有意义的。
对,
然后我们刚刚提到了关于大家问医生，
所有的这些回答他是不是专业的，
OpenAI他是发了一个评价标准，
叫做Health Bench,。
他可以用真实的对话场景，
而不是选择题来去测AI的能力基准，
而且他是由262位来自于60个国家26个专科，
49种语言去做的一个评分标准，
我看他的评分标准的结果是，
他的O3模型的得分是60%，
如果你把题变成非常难耗的模式，
他的最高分是32%，
我想请叶斌可不可以给大家科普一下，
比如说在OpenAI做Health Bench之前，
我们去测这些AI的医疗能力，
主要是用什么方法，
他现在的60%的得分是什么意思，
就是说他紧紧拿了一个60分吗？
是我们可以去相信AI吗？
其实是他这个Health Bench的想法非常好啊，
我们去评价医生好不好，
比如说你去看病，
那你肯定是一个对话的，
就是说我最近发烧或者是我喉咙痛，
那个医生根据你给出的症状给你一个判断，
然后他会有继续问了一些信息，
可能你要告诉我来帮你判断，
但是如果你去读医学院做医生，
那他首先要经历的是什么？
他是考试，考你医学知识，
以前的AI的评分吧，
如果是医学方面的，
大家可能也看到过，
比如说Chat GPT，
他那个考美国的医生执照的那个考试，
能考多少分，比很多医生考的都高，
那个就是选择体他在考试。
那现在这个Health Bench，
他的评价是通过几百位医生，
总共筛选出来一个评分标准，
相当于他模拟出来的，
怎么样一个对话，
人家病人来问你一个什么问题，
你应该要覆盖到哪几个点，
你应该用什么样的语言去回答他，
你的回答要能够安抚这个患者，
比如说有个人说，
我看到我的邻居昏倒了，
应该怎么办？
那么这个问题，
如果你用一个Chat GPT来问这个问题，
那Chat GPT应该要涵盖哪几点，
才能是做得对的。
这个就是看一个具体的医疗场景，
他的表现符不符合最佳的医学的推荐，
不再是原来的，
我问你血糖多少是正常，
这个就是一个考知识点的，
这和以前的就不一样了，
像以前好像有一个叫MedQA，
还有一个叫PubMedQA，
那么MedQA相当于是测试一个。
书本的临床知识，
PubQA是测试你对科学文献这方面的了解，
现在Healthbench和他们两个是完全不一样了，
这个更多的是一个真实的医疗场景下，
你应该给出关于医疗的回答，
应该覆盖到哪些方面，
因为好像他们还拿这个去让医生去做了，
医生做出来很多也不太一样，
这个60分看他具体情况怎么样，
在有一些我看到的他们最后测试的结果，
比如说是急救这样的一个情况，
他的得分相对来说是比较高的，
还有一些常见子病，
比如说高血压这样的处理，
他的得分也是比较高的，
就证明从医学证据上，
你应该要覆盖东西，
他能够比较高的一个比例覆盖到，
当然如果把他那个难度调高了，
可能这个得分就下来了，
那可能就证明一些比较困难的疾病，
还是比较难以面面俱到的一个问题，
比如说是急救这个情景做的比较好，
那么在急诊室里面，
可能这个模型你加于一个改进，
你可以帮助医生去判断，
或者是帮助一个普通人判断那也行的，
比如说你就看到一个人昏倒了，
那么你可以问一下chatgpd，
说不定这个chatgpd。
能给你一个比较好的建议，
这也是可以的，
如果是一个比较低的分数，
那就要看的是他到底差在哪些方面，
有一些关键的问题，
如果是没有回答到，
那确实是一个比较大的问题。
所以简单来说，
以前测AI医疗的水平，
就是让他去做选择题，
那chatgpd他应该是很早就能考到90分以上，
但是Healthbench相当于让AI真的去做诊，
然后让200多个医生从十几个维度去打分，
而且我发现这个测试他还有一个扣分像，
就是说如果AI他犯的错误很危险，
就会被扣分，
所以他有可能是到零分甚至是负分的。
所以我们再来去看一下这个60%的含金量，
他其实是比选择题的90分要高得多的是这样吗？
是的，是的。
最后其实我还有一个问题，
就是你们觉得是不是AI医疗这条路还是巨头的天下？
我并不觉得他会是巨头的天下，
因为一来是说医疗场景市场很巨大，
同时他也非常多样，
他的应用场景是非常多变的，
所以从巨头的角度来讲，他不太可能整体覆盖。
二来的话，在医疗领域，
其实巨头除了模型之外，
像他做很多其他的应用，
他有很大的优势是在于数据优势，
但是在医疗领域，
大部分的核心的医疗数据，
实际上是在不同的机构手中，
还有医院、系统、药厂、医疗公司等等，
这些大的公司，
他是不会愿意把自己所有的数据都分享给。
其他的这些大的巨头科技公司的。
相对来讲的话，
他们更愿意和出创企业合作，
他会觉得自己的掌控度会更高一点，
而且出创企业他可能做的产品。
也会更加细分、更加垂直。
所以从这个角度来讲的话，
比较难说大头去垄断或者说去覆盖。
当然有些比如说底层的项目提到。
比较偏软件层的EHR这些系统的话，
很可能是本身它也是软件层嘛，
那可能是从一些科技公司的角度。
进行工作流程的一个植入，
会更好做。
但即使这样的话，
你会看到各种各样这种。
工作流程相关的一些细分的应用，
出创企业会崛起成长速度非常快。
还有最后一点的话，
这个行业它是一个高监管行业，
信任值很重要。
那你的数据怎么部署，
谁去hosting，谁去拥有？
这个对于很多医疗公司。
还有说医疗领域的机构来讲，
是非常关键的。
在过去这些年，
整个医疗系统对于科技行业。
在数据隐次层面上的信任度。
是相对比较低的。
更不用说，
如果说很多数据要去放在。
云服务层面上，
哪怕是有它黑帕合规，
它还是有很多的确定性，
一旦胜和这些合规风险出现，
像我提到的，
集体诉讼情况出现，
那最后，
一定要承担这个责任，
或者说后果的，
还是医疗公司。
所以从他们风险控制的角度的话，
它更不愿意把一个巨大的风险。
绑定在一家大的企业上，
而是说把各个小风险。
风扇到多家的技术。
供应商，
或者AI技术的服务上。
AnswerRopic Cloud,。
前几天，
它出了一个plug-in，
这个plug-in出了以后，
其实整个sense行业，
它的股价是在大跌的。
我看它里面还有一个板块，
是for health care,。
然后你刚刚提到了，
从合规的角度来讲，
大家难道不是会更加信任一个，
你已经很有reputation的巨头，
它还同时各种地方宣传说，
我拿了各种各样的合规牌照，
它不会是大公司，
反而它的一种优势吗？
而且我觉得还有一点，
是因为它的模型的能力，
更强,
我们可以理解，
整体上它是处于一种，
更加智慧的状态。
在医疗领域的话呢，
当然模型能力强是个优势，
但更重要的是说，
合规，安全无幻觉，
这个可能比它模型能力强，
是更重要的一个必须的要求，
然后再去看哪个模型能力更强，
就比如说，
你说大的整体模型能力，
它比较强，
但是在单一的，
一个应用场景层面上的话，
垂直领于小模型，
它的模型能力，
是可以针对这个应用场景，
优化到非常好的一个程度的，
它是可以和这些大的公司进行竞争的，
所以在模型能力，
在单个应用场景层面上出创解释，
可以有优势的，
或者说至少可以打一个平手，
然后你说Cloud，
我们刚才也聊过了，
Cloud它做的不是应用端，
它其实做的是底层基础测试，
这也是它比较聪明的一个答法，
它可能作为一个大的技术解决方案，
会更容易获得一些信任，
但即使这样，
你可以去观察它的推进速度，
还是相对比较慢的，
除了安全和合规，
另外一点的话呢，
其实就像我们其道应用场景很多样，
数据的基础设施也很多样，
并不是说美国所有的医院，
或者医疗公司，医疗公司，
它用的什么云服务，
还有它的Cloud infrastructure,。
都是一致的，
它其实还是有很多碎片化的，
或者说个性化的特点，
那作为一个标准化服务的技术平台，
比如说像Cloud或者其他大的公司，
它去做个性化服务，
或个性化产品投放的可能性，
就会低很多，
因为对它来讲，
它也比较靠，
但初创起就有这个灵活度。
对，那你们觉得2C市场是有机会的吗？
我觉得这个需求是肯定在的，
我觉得现在在医疗界，
一个非常有趣的现象，
那就是大家把tels和wellness的区分，
你看那个wellness，
很多都是2C的，
tels的话,
大家可以想象去医院看一个医生，
但很多时候，
我们对健康的需求，
超过了医院，医生可以提供的，
我们甚至希望这个wellness，
很多时候就变成了，
我们在网上看到，
某个人给大家讲，
你怎么把自己的生活的状态给提升啊，
这方面，
它有一些会和医疗有相关，
它有时候又超出了，
但是还有很多人在看这些，
那就证明大家对这方面的需求，
实在是太高了，
可能有些公司，
哪怕说我不想给你来提供诊疗服务，
大家还是在用，
还是在问chatgpt，
那么最后还是存在于那里的，
只不过问题就是说，
2C最后能不能做成功，
但是由于现在AI模型的特征，
哪怕你不是完全是做医疗的一个模型，
它还是能够提供一些建议，
它最后还是会做到这一块儿。
对，而且你刚刚提到wellness，
我觉得它是一个特别好的点，
其实我前一段时间在看，
超越百岁那本书，
它里面有一个观点我还挺认同的，
它就说过去我们在一个医疗2.0的时代，
大家如果有病的话，
它是先生了病，
然后再去寻求治疗，
但是呢，
其实现在我们正在走到一个医疗3.0的时代，
比如说现在我们的苹果手机，
电子手表，
还有一些智能戒指，
它是可以追踪到很多我们个人的，
平时生活习惯的数据的，
包括其实我们自己去就医的时候，
也会有各种各样的数据。
它是可以在我们健康发生重大危机以前，
就是我们通过各种智能监测，
提前预防这些疾病，
不是说等到了有病再治，
而是说通过这些数据更好的，
主动的去管理自己的健康，
可能在问题发生以前，
就把这个问题给拦戒下来。
其实有的时候，我拿到这些数据的时候，
我也有一点不清楚这个数据是什么意思，
以及要怎么做。
就是从消费者的角度啊，
丢给弹幕型有的时候还是很有用的，
而且我觉得如果能出现类似这方面的一些垂直应用，
我可能也都会还蛮感兴趣的，
就纯粹从消费者的角度来讲。
对啊，因为其实我们就要说，
未来的医疗的发展方向，
真正的事叫Colorative Life,。
就是生命的质量，生活的质量，
你要去保证生命的质量，
就是说我们不只是要活的久，
而是说在八九十岁甚至一百岁的时候，
身体还很健壮，大脑也很清晰，
想要达到这个结果，
就是你提到的要去更多的叫Preventive Health，
就是你怎么样可以去预防疾病的发生，
或者说在疾病发生的早期去进行诊断，
进行个性化的治疗，
而且可以在疾病对身体损伤相对效小的一个阶段，
进行治疗和恢复。
这都是未来医疗发展的方向，
而现在我们有的这些海量的高质量的医疗数据在辅助于AI，
就是可以帮助我们把很多的数据连接起来。
其实以前我们经常讲诊断，
大家对诊断的一个概念，它就是一个点的动作，
就是你去看医生在当下有什么疾病去进行诊断，
但其实你想想我们整体无论是身体的变化，
还有疾病的演变，还有免疫系统的变化，
它是一个持续的过程，
所以现在所有的这些智能设备，还有数据的收集，
可以帮助我们进行持续的监控和持续的诊断，
那这些数据不仅可以帮助我们更早的补货疾病，
而且也可以给医生去提供更多的数据基础，
去进行个性化的诊断和治疗，
就日常身体的质量的维护，
还有很重要的一点就是我们现在会很多讨论Longevity，
承受科技，那可行就是我刚才提到的生命的治疗，
所以现在很多新的技术其实并不是把诊断和治疗分得那么开，
它是说有个性化诊断有个性化治疗，
两边的数据是可以整合，进行相对应的，
而且好处是之前其实也会发现有很多技术专注在早期诊断，
但是没有治疗手段，所以很多时候大家也会去探讨，
一方面是你有什么解决方案你如果诊断出这个疾病，
那在没有解决方案的情况下怎么办，
二来是由于没有治疗手段也会导致在早期诊断。
和预防层面上投入的资金和资源不够大，
但现在的好处是很多疾病都已经有了比较成熟的，
可以开始进入临床的治疗手段，
大家就会更愿意在预防类的技术，
还有早期诊断技术上去进行投资，
大家也会否明确地说我早期诊断是有好处的，
因为我可以早期去把这个疾病治疗掉，
而不是像之前有技术说可以在病人的老年痴呆十年前就诊断出这个疾病，
但是这个对于人来讲如果没有老年痴呆的治疗手段是很可怕的一件事情，
你就会想说哎那十年之后我是不是不得这样的一个疾病，
所以现在它是一个整个生态的持续演变的发展。
对，叶斌你怎么看？
从技术上来说，那以后肯定这样的技术越来越多，
然后同时也是大家的关注嘛，
以前我是生病，我把这个病治好，
现在大家可能关注是我的整体的一个健康的状态，
这个方面的话医院本身就比较难做这样的事情，
这让我想起以前做基因测试的时候，
比如说我们做医疗诊断的肿瘤的，
我们给它做个测试，看出来它这个肿瘤是哪个突变，
我们给它用哪一个把向药，
如果是2C的话，那么就变成23andMe，
给大家做个测试告诉一下你有哪些突变，
那个2C最后没有成功，那是因为这个测试它只是一次性的，
你测完一次你不可能说我还要再去测一个23andMe，
因为人的DNA它是不可能变的，
那么就导致它这个市场是非常有限的，
但是我们提到的AI的医疗就不一样了，
因为我们对身体的关注，这个是持续的，
理论上来说它应该是一个非常广泛的市场，
当然它可能不像直接连接到原来的医院那一块，
你就可以想象做肿瘤的分子检测，
毕竟每天都有那么多癌症病人去医院，
而且现在有越来越多的新药，
它就需要能够确定你是这个突变才能用这个药，
它也会愿意来为这个付钱，
2C这方面的话可能这方面就稍微差一点，
如果OpenAI它要收费的话，
有些人就说那我找个免费了可不可以，
这可能是一大挑战，
但是另外一方面它这个市场确实是存在于那里的。
对，那聊到最后我有一个很强烈的感受，
就是AI医疗这件事，
它其实不是一个未来的概念，
它已经在发生了，
而且其实今天我们也聊到了很多像幻觉的问题，
隐私的问题，
谁为AI的判断负责的问题，
我觉得路有一句话说的特别好，
就我们需要Human in the Loop,。
AI是工具，医生才是主体，
那叶斌的分流分层我也很认同，
AI未必真的要去替代最好的医生，
但是它可以让大家在凌晨3点不舒服的时候，
至少有一个靠谱的第一步。
那这个领域我相信，
2026年一定会发生更多的大的变化，
我们也会持续关注，
谢谢陆，谢谢叶斌。
谢谢。
最后本期节目不构成任何的投资建议，
也欢迎大家在小宇宙苹果波克Sportify上。
来订阅我们，
也可以通过B站还有YouTube搜索。
硅谷101波克来收听订阅，
我是红军，我们下期见。